[Música]
dice víctor frankl en su libro el hombre
busca el sentido último el único que
tiene el hombre de humano es su espíritu
el mundo en el que vivimos nos pide
pensar en qué auto comprar perro para
ponernos nos dice cómo tenemos que
actuar está cool y enoja
es extraño que siendo lo únicos nos
pasemos la vida tratando de imitar a
otros o pretendiendo ser que no somos la
necesidad de pretende de pertenecer nos
ha llevado a perder nuestra esencia
ahora es más importante un like de un
desconocido que conocernos a nosotros
mismos es más importante la marca de
ropa que usamos que nuestra misma
existencia es más importante la
ascensión del hotspot y disfrutar y
asombrarnos del entorno
todo esto nos lleva a la vaciedad de
espíritu
por lo tanto alejarnos de nuestra
humanidad y del verdadero ser
buenas tardes
cuando me invitaron a dar esta plática
luces por comunicar dar esta plática
descendimos contento que fuera la
singular el genio porque porque
considero que todos somos genios en
potencia ahora les voy a explicar por
qué mi trabajo va a ayudar a hacerlo
mi obra sería entre series ver un volume
y pulcro vamos a comenzar por verme pero
no es la verdad si éste es narciso se
sabe en la historia narciso sí bueno
narciso se enamora tanto a sí mismo que
se ahoga en un lago es de la mitología
griega
todos somos narcisismo actualmente
estamos tan enamorados de nuestro
pretender ser tan enamorados de nuestro
yo virtual que nos estamos ahogando en
este mundo es un mundo abierto al un
mundo que no existe nosotros creamos la
relatividad en este universo
la verdad es un concepto muy difícil de
explicar porque por lo mismo es relativa
talento yo tomo como elemento único y
verdadero nuestra huella digital esta es
una verdad absoluta al igual que el
mundo lo pongo en el lugar del rostro
para recordarnos que somos verdaderos
somos únicos y así fuimos concebidos de
nuestro origen no tenemos por qué
pretender tenemos que ser tenemos que
conocernos a nosotros mismos una vez que
nos conozcamos a nosotros mismos podemos
empezar a contar encontrar la verdad en
todo lo demás que nos rodea
agradable con un mono es la bondad
ustedes creen que este ser sea malo
no sí
entonces creen que es bueno
no bueno decía rousseau que todos lo
hacemos buenos nos tornamos malos por
experiencia una clave lo decía lo
contrario que todos somos malos y nos
tardamos buenos por instrucción
yo digo que todos somos puros y somos el
resultado de nuestras experiencias
sin embargo tenemos en nuestro ser
conciencia es esto que nos hace decir
que está bien y que está mal no tenemos
intrínseco nada no tiene que decir que
matar o quitarle la vida a alguien está
mal que ven en esta imagen
les parece tierna y les parece una niña
bonita
esta niña es mía
ahora qué opinan
se entiende que es una pistola
bueno
mi hija nació en ambiente amable la
queremos todos los días le decimos te
amo va a una escuela en donde la
respetan
cuando eso es cultura me pregunta papá
porque tengo la pistola neutro y me si
usted es que voy a jugar con agua en la
sala y no me dejas para mí esa fue una
respuesta padrísima que venga de vida
pero qué pasa si esta niña hubiera
nacido en siria
entonces en alepo yo le digo toma esta
pistola central y por esa puerta te vas
a defender
esta niña su concepción de la bondad
duración muy diferente a la concepción
de la bondad que tiene mira y si esta
misma niña fuera hija de un arco
al borde me pregunta por la pistola
porque porque la pistola existe en su
casa todos los días sabe para qué se
utiliza algo me ha dicho porque le
pusiste steve
no
pero bueno sin embargo la niña de siria
puede tomar una decisión puede ser ser
mártir
este es pinocho
en 8 no es una historia de niños se los
va a contar de volada mucho no piden
hacer es creado él es feliz como es el
bueno que sale a la calle y no empiezan
a influenciar es cuando él se da cuenta
que es diferente toma esta diferencia y
él pretende ser una estrella pero todo
ello la voz de la conciencia siempre le
está diciendo regresa a regresa por aquí
no va por aquí nuestro tema entonces él
sigue con todo este tema pero se da
cuenta que lo están utilizando que están
por la nouvelle y logra escaparse y
mucho sigue su camino después entonces
empieza en el tema de los vicios el
relajo etcétera en este one delante de
pinta la película de disney en el libro
es un poco diferente y mucho más canijo
pero bueno entonces esté mezclando un
pedazo de la película de disney que se
más fabuloso en el mandante pinocho se
aleja de su conciencia la deja de
escuchar y se vuelve un animal que pasó
con pinocho pinocho perdió su voluntad y
su razón son los dos elementos que nos
regalaron pero esta voluntad y razón se
supone que nosotros podemos decidir
desgraciadamente esta misma voluntad y
razón en lugar de volvernos los seres
más maravillosos de la creación nos
vuelve esclavos de nuestras mismas
pasiones
ahora vamos a hablar un poquito del
pulcro que es la integración de los
demás conceptos el pulcro mes la belleza
es el universo es todo lo que nos rodea
han oído hablar de la secuencia
fibonacci
bueno un colega mío español cristóbal
vinader estudios no nos va a prestar uno
de sus vídeos para que lo vean y creo
que va a quedar muy claro todo el tema
del pulcro por favor
[Música]
ah
y
[Música]
no no
y
cristóbal termina subido casualmente con
una libélula esto que están viendo atrás
es una de mis piezas se llama este
dragon fly y es justamente tomar el ala
de la libélula magnificarla y ver la
perfección en ella tenemos triángulos
cuadrados pentágonos hexágonos cepta
bonos que se repiten exponencialmente y
sirve y si el ala fuera más grande se
seguirían repitiendo hasta el infinito
absolutamente un autobús el nautile es
esta concha de este animal acuático en
el cual está basado el turno de los
autos de los aviones
el submarino le echo oliver no le puso
nautilus a una de sus
en su obra
y esto nautilus tiene cámaras interiores
que permite que se sumerja ok ok o que
flote o que vaya lo más rápido posible
no va en el agua entonces este
todos los grandes inventos de la del
humano están basados en la naturaleza
les voy a platicar un poquito más de mi
insecto favorito que son las abejas
este animalito que no tiene razón genera
estos hexágonos perfectos que contienen
la mayor cantidad de miel posible y
genera una estructura lo suficientemente
fuerte para sostener a tu el panal como
es que un ser que no tiene razón puede
generar esto para este conocimiento
intrínseco pero también por bueno por lo
tanto al ser matemática es verdadera
pero también son buenas pero porque son
buenas porque por que polinizan grasa la
polinización hay oxígeno pero no hay
plantas atrás a la planta de oxígeno y
gracias al oxígeno estamos aquí
platicando y todos nosotros por las
abejas que es lo que hacen las abejas
buscan un bien universal
decía platón que sí es bueno y es
verdadero es esencialmente bello la
belleza va mucho más allá de la estética
la belleza tiene que ser manu y tiene
que ser verdadera
estas abejas que generan un bien
universal a la vez generan un bien para
su panal y a la vez generando un bien
personal si el ser humano llegar a
comprender esto sin ser humano llegar a
comprender que nosotros generando un
bien mucho más allá de nuestra misma
existencia podríamos también generamos
un bien personal otra cosa sería el ser
humano es el único animal de la
naturaleza que pisotea a las demás
especies y también se pisotea a sí mismo
con tal de lograr un objetivo personal
todos estamos conectados
todos somos uno
1 la palabra 1 es el entendimiento que
somos mucho más que un simple individuo
han oído a los y sanz quien dijo esta
frase
mira profundamente la naturaleza observa
profundamente la naturaleza y entenderás
mejor todo
nadie me dio
pero dijo albert einstein sale
el hombre está hecho para contemplar no
está hecho para oír para ver para tocar
por aparte está hecho para contemplar
está hecho para poner sus cinco sentidos
en un solo instante conectarse con el
universo y en ese momento es donde se da
la singularidad el genio es en ese
momento donde el hombre es capaz de
crear ese en ese instante en donde el
hombre puede transformar el mundo
[Música]
muchas gracias